- About where advertising ends.
All those guys don't work anymore.
- Yeah. It's so over stlying.
- They heard like cattle and sheep.
- That's so interesting.
- Play and play and play until
he couldn't play anymore.
- Okay, okay, you're a grown man
and you should really close
your mouth when you eat.
- You know what, I don't
care. Whatever dude.
- [Co-Worker] She is just very sensitive
and I don't think that you should--
I don't get it.
- You know what, you know
what, you're right. I'm sorry.
- So it's worth exploring
the beauty of it and
(phone ringing) we have noticed
(phone ringing) I--
Can we find the phone that's ringing guys?
- Moms love us (phone ringing)
so, let's just keep that up.
- (phone ringing) The wires can break.
(phone ringing) The wires can break.
(phone ringing) You can
actually take that outside.
- [Date] It's all great.
Yeah, I can't believe the magic now.